[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر البركه
احييكم
تجاره غير مشروعه
وسطى ازمه دولار سببها داخلي واول حلولها
في واشنطن العراق يعفي محافظه البنك
المركزي
بمنع التهريب
انواع
الدبابات وروسيا تصف اي محاوله لمسي
اصولها المجمده بالسرقه
عن خبايا حائط الصواريخ في سوريا
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
اربحون اربحوا عمالقه التكنولوجيا فقاعه
فجرها التضخم والركود واوضاع استثنائيه
ذهبت معا حصار كورونا
ديناره يتلقى صدمه وراء اخرى امام الدولار
والاسباب بعضها على ارضه والبعض الاخر على
بعد الاف الاموال لكن رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد السوداني اكد امكانيه الحصول
على الدولار لتغطيه عمليات الاستيراد
مستغربا اللجوء للسوق السوداء
ان يكون ارتفاع سعر صرف الدولار في البلاد
قرارا حكميا مؤكدا
عليها بين المؤسسات الماليه والبنك
المركزيه واكد رئيس الوزراء العراقي انا
حكومته جاده في تطبيق المعايير الصحيحه
التي تضمن المحافظه على المال العام ومنع
تهريب وغسيل الاموال والمبارك
اعفى محافظ البنك المركزي مصطفى غالب
مخيفه من
وكل فعالي محسن العلاق بادارته بالوكاله
من يحاول استغلال الازمه واللعب على اوجاع
الناس واعتياجاتها
لم يرتفع سعر صرف نتيجه قرار حكومي انما
لانه هناك من استغل الظروف الوقتيه
والاضطراب في الاسواق التي لم تالف بعده
التعامل مع الخطوات والاليات المصرفيه
الجديده التي ستحافظ على اموال الشعب وهي
خطوه مهمه على طريق الاصلاح الاقتصادي
ونؤكد هنا
على اولويه مكافحه جائحه الفساد فلا يمكن
لاي جهد ان يتكلم بالنجاح طالما بقيت هذه
الجائحه قادره على الانتقال والانتشار في
جسد الدوله
في العراق يكفي الانخفاض المشهود في قيمه
الدينار مقابل الدولار
عن نحو عشره بالمئه طبعا كل هذا بموجب
تطبيق قواعد صارمه فرضتها واشنطن على
تعاملات البنك المركزي العراقي مع تجار
العمله وتفرد هذه الاجراءات على المصارف
العراقيه تقديم تحويلات بالدولار على منصه
جديده على الانترنت مع المركزي العراقي
لتتم مراجعتها بعد ذلك من قبل بنك
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي الامريكي
الغرض اعلنت واشنطن هو الحد من استخدام
النظام المصرفيه العراقي لتهريب الدولارات
الى طهران ودمشق وما لا ذات غسل الاموال
في انحاء الشرق الاوسط قد تكون الاجراءات
لكن ما المشكله في العراق
المركزي العراقي فان المنصه المتعلقه
بطلبات الحصول على الدولار تطلب تفاصيل
كامله عن العملاء الذين يريدون تحويلات
ماليه بما في ذلك المستفيدون النهائيون
هنا تظهر المشكله حيث يرتكب العملاء
العديد من الاخطاء عند تقدمهم بطلبات
للحصول على الدولار وحين تتم مراجعه
البيانات
واكتشاف الاخطاء يطلب من البنوك تصحيحها
وهذا الامر يستغرق الكثيره من الوقت
لن ننسى ان هناك محطتين لتنقيح البيانات
البنوك العراقيه ثم الجانب الامريكي
لانه منذ بدء التطبيق هذه الاليات تم حظر
80 بالمئه او اكثر من التحويلات اليوميه
بالدولار في العراق التي بلغ مجموعها في
السابق اكثر من 250 مليون دولار في بعض
الايام
الصحيفه فان العراق يعاني من صدمه لانه
سمح بتجاوز كثير من التعليمات المصرفيه
العالميه طوال عقدين من الزمن في كل الاح
القرار الامريكي قبل باعتراضات كثيره
اهمها من رئيس الوزراء محمد الشع-
السوداني الذي قال ان القرار يضر بالفقراء
وكشف عن ارسال وفد الى واشنطن لمناقشه
تعليق الاليه لسته اشهر
الى العراق وندخل اكثر في تفاصيل الازمه
مع منتظر الرشيد من هنا
تشهدوا البورصه الماليه المحليه في بغداد
في جانبي الكرخي والرصافه انخفاضا كبيرا
في عمليات بيعه وشراء الدولار على خلفيه
تذبذبي اسعاره سعر الصرفي مؤخرا
اقبال التجار لتمويل الشراء بضائعهم على
سحب كميات كبيره من الدولار عن طريق السوق
السوداء بعيدا عن البنك المركزي للتهربي
من المساءله القانونيه والضرائب ادى الى
ارتفاع سعر الصرفي في الاسواق المحليه
البنك المركزي ولي الحدي من ارتفاع سعر
صرف الدولار اكد انه زود المصارف الحكوميه
بكميات كبيره من الدولار وباسعار الرسميه
لكن ذلك الى الان لم يفلح في كبح جماح
الاسعار من بغداد منتظر الرشيد العربيه
الاولاني ازمه اقتصاديه 100% واكثر شيء
حرب على مواطن العراقي المسكين الفقير لان
تعرف المواد الغذائيه كلها بالدولار واحنا
بلد غير صناعي وبلد غير زراعي كل اشترادي
فاكيد المواطن العراقي هو اللي تاذن
الوحيد
المواطن العراقي الفقير هو يتادب هذا
الموضوع صعود الدولار وهديه كبرى عليه
الاسباب سياسيه طبعا واضحه انه هو بده
يصير تضارب بسعر صرف الدولار وهذه
الارتفاع اللي يصير مثل ما تعرف البنك
المركزي يبيع على ال 146 ونصف والسوق ده
يحكمك انه تبيع بسعر اعلى لان يسوقه وسعر
البورصه والمزاد العالي
[موسيقى]
فهذا السبب همم يعني اعتقد اشوف التهريب
العمله الى خارج البلاد ياثر على هذا
الشيء ده اعتبرها عقوبات امريكيه على
العراق
معنى من لندن صادق الركابي مدير المركز
العالميه للدراسات التنمويه اهلا بك معنا
استاذ صادق في العربيه 360 ونريد ان نبدا
معك بتشخيص المشكله هل الحقيقه كما قال
السيد محمد شيعه السوداني رئيس الوزراء
لانه المشكله كانت في الاليه التي توفي
عليها بين البنك المركزي والمؤسسات
الماليه وبالتالي الاجراءات التي اتخذها
ستاتي اكلها
نعم تحيه لكم همم جزء من هذا الكلام صحيح
هناك او منصه الانتقال الالكتروني التي
كانت تنصح بها الخزانه الامريكيه قبل
عامين وليس الان وحتى صندوق النقد الدولي
كان ينصح بها لتمويل التجاره الدوليه ومع
ذلك يقوم بذلك بهذه النصيحه همم ولكن كانت
المسارت العراقيه ترفض الامتثال لهذا
الامر لان اغلب الفواتير التي يتم بموجبها
استيراد السلاح هي فواتير مزوره بحسب
دائره الوقايه في هيئه النزاهه الاتحاد
الاحاديه التي اعلنت في تقرير ان حجم
الضرر لسنه واحده فقط كان اكثر من اربعه
مليون دينار بسبب تزوير هذه الفواتير
الامر الاخر انه في اجتماع جرى في عمان
اطلعت الخزانه الامريكيه مسؤولين في البنك
المركزي العراقي هذا جرى في مؤخره مؤخره
يعني في ديسمبر تحديدا اطلعت الخزانه
الامريكيه المسؤولين العراقيين المانيين
على تسلسل الارقام دولارات همم
وجدت هذه كانت مخصصه كايرادات النفط
العراقي تذهب من الفيدران الامريكي الى
الخزينه العراقيه وجدت هذه الدولارات عند
تتبعها في دول مجاوره وجدت في ايران وفي
دول اخرى وهذه الدول كانت عرضه وهي تحت
العقوبات وبالتالي خلال لقاء السفير
الامريكيه مع السيد محمد الشاعر السوداني
خلال عده مرات كانت تسر السفيره الامريكيه
على ضروره التجنيد ان يكون العراق منفدا
لدول هي عرضه للعقبات وهي كانت تلمح الى
ايران تحديدا
هناك طريقه اخرى لا يتاذى فيها الفقراء
بالعراق يعني هناك تضرر كبير ان كان من
الفقراء او التجار الذين لم يراعوا في هذا
الموضوع
الى هذه المنصه واعتقد انها لمصلحه
الاقتصاد عراقي هي لمصلحه الفقراء لان
اغلب
والى مسار هي واجهات لهذه الاحزاب والدول
المجاوره للعراق وبالتالي هي لا تذهب
للفقراء وهذه الاليه اذا تم الالتزام بها
تضمن ان تذهب الاموال عائلات النفط
العراقي الى الشعب العراقي ولا تكون هذه
المصارف مجرد واجهات لغسيل هذه الاموات بس
الاستاذ صادق عندما تقول يعني عندما نعلم
بانه الاحتياط الفدرالي رفض 80% من طلبات
التحويلات الماليه للمصارف العراقيه الى
الخارج منذ بدء التقييد او بتنفيذ منذ
تنفيذ هذه القيود هل كل هذا غسيل اموال
تهريب الى الخارج طيب انا اعطيك مثال رقمي
في العمل 2015 كان سقف الاحتياط سقف البنك
المركزي في استيراد السلعه كان 75 مليون
دولار تكفي لحاجه الشعب العراقي الذي كان
وقتها 35 مليون نسمه خلال خمس سنوات فقط
اصبح الرقم سقف البنك المركزي اللي نافذه
العمله اصبح ثلاث مئه مليون
الدولار رغم ان الشعب العراقي لم يزداد
عدده بهذه الكميات الضخمه وهذا الدليل على
ان معظم هذه المبالغ هي لي
ست الشعب العراقي وخلال اجتماع الخزينه
الامريكيه مع المسؤولين العراقيين اطلعوهم
على مثال بسيط قالوا لهم يوجد لدينا
فواتير باستيراد مليون ثلاجه او مليون
براد بقيمه 4000 دولار لكل ثلاجه وبالتالي
هذا رقم كبير على حاجه الشعب العراقي ولا
ضروره لاستيراده خلال فتره قصيره هذا فقط
رقم بسيط يعطيك دليل على حجم التزوير
الموجود في هذه النافذه
ابقى معنا
سنستمع الى
العراقيين ماذا قالوا عن تاثير ارتفاع
الدولار على العراقيين ثم نعود اليك سيد
صادق
صار ثلاثه بالف صمون صعب دجاج ودجاج
يعني كل شيء صعب هي الدوله ما اعرف شو
تريد ما اعرف لان هو اصلا التاجر يشتغل
بالدولار
فمن يكسر سعر الدولار القطعه اذا كانت
بدولار ان قلت كان سعرها الف ونص الدولار
1600 دينار فهي الماده اساسا هي سعرها
دولاب فمن يزيد الدولار بسبب
الدولار
حتى العامل البسيطه اثر عليه المشكله هي
الدولار يصعد ماكو تعويض يعني مثلا هسه
احنا مثلا نشتريها بالدولار انا لازم شو
اسوي لازم اشتري عراقي اشتري عراقي اخذ
دولار مكان كنت اشتري قبل عن 120 و 25 ب
150 160 ودي اروح اسافر هناك
جديد سيد صادق يعني رئيس الوزراء محمد
شعاع السوداني تحدث عن ارسال وفد عراقي
رسمي الى واشنطن لمناقشه تعليق هذا القرار
او هذه الاليه لمده سته اشهر ما الذي
سيقنع واشنطن بتعليق هذه الاليه اصلا
وماذا بعد السته اشهر ما الاليه المثلى
التي ستكون لصالح العراقيين
نعم اعتقد ان السيد السوداني عليه ان يعرض
الى الاداره الامريكيه التزام العراق
بالقوانين الدوليه وعن يعني يثبت لهم
بالارقام ان العراق ملتزم بمنع عمليات
غسيل الاموال لكن اعتقد ان ما سيحدث خلال
هذا الاجتماع هو ان الاداره الامريكيه
وتحديد على الخزانه الامريكيه ستعرض له
كيف بالدليل ولا ارقام اصبحت هذه الاموال
تذهب بالفعل الى المستفيد النهائي النهائي
وانها كانت سابقا لا تقوم بذلك وستساله
ايضا لماذا الان امتنعت المصارف العراقيه
عن التزام بهذه المنصه طالما انك تقول
بانها المصارف هذه تستورد سلع وهي حاجه
الشعب العراقي اذا لماذا لم تلتزم هذه
المصارف اذا كانت جاده بهذه المنصه
الالكترونيه وبالتالي تخدم الشعب العراقي
يعني بين قوسين تلعب او تتلاعب بالسوق
بدون شك وربما يزيد هذا الامر سوءا لاحقا
كما حصل في دول عديده وكما يحصل في لبنان
مثلا همم هل باعتقادك السيد سوداني قادر
على ضبط هؤلاء عندما يحين الوقت ام ان
الموضوع مرشح فعلا لان يصبح ازمه كارثه
اقتصاديه وماليه كما حصل في لبنان
يعني انا انا كنت اظن ان السيد السوداني
سيخرج بتصريح يقول با
ن البيئه الاعتماد المنصه الجديده
والابتعاد عن نافذه بيع العمله السابقه
ولكنه قام باجراءات يعني جانبيه لا يعني
تجابه الازمه وبالتالي قام بتبديل
المحافظه وكان المشكله هي بالمحافظ ولا
ننسى ان هذا المحافظ هو كان ايام المالكي
وكان مسؤول عن كثير من الفزا الفساد
الموجود في نافذه بيعه العمله وبالتالي
اجراءات السيد السوداني لا لا يعني تجاري
ما تطلبه الخزانه الامريكيه ولحد الان هو
لم يتخذ الاجراءات الحقيقيه التي تعالج
هذه المشكله شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ صادق
الركابي مدير المركز العالمي للدراسات
تنميه من لندن تحياتنا اليك
[موسيقى]
وتتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا
عقبه قانونيه امام تصنيف اوروبا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشف دراسه عسكريه عن نقص
كبير في مخزون السلاح الامريكي بسبب
اوكرانيا الدراسيه
استهلكت مخزونه سبع سنوات من انتاج امريكا
لصواريخ
في وقت الحرب الولايات المتحده من مشكلات
في الذخيره اذا واجهت الصين عسكريا قريبا
تعاني من تاخير في استلام الذخيره
وبينما تعاني الولايات المتحده من نقص
ذخيره تعاني المانيا من انتقادات الحلفاء
بسبب تاخرها في اعتماد الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا بالدبابات وبالتحديد طراز وبورد
لكن برلين دفعت عن نفسها واكدت ان هدفها
هو ككل المعسكر الغربي ان يتم تحرير
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بين قاده اوروبا في خضم معركه ايراده
الجدل والاتهامات المواجهه لبرلين
بالتقاعس عن دعم كيف على منسوبها بين
الحلفاء الغربي المانيا في الاتهامات تاره
وتقول انها ليست حجره عثره في طريق تزويد
اوكرانيا
لكن اذا طلب منا فلن نقف في الطريق
الدبابات المطلوبه ليس للتجول في الشارع
ليدافع الاوكرانيون عن انفسهم افهموا مدى
اهميه هذه الدبابات وندرك ذلك تماما لهذا
السبب نحن مع جميع شركائنا في عمليه
المشاورات
وتاره اخرى تدعو الى التحلي بالصبر بشان
قرار ارسال دبابات اليو بارك الى الجيش
الاوكراني فمصلحه بيرلين تتمثل في اتخاذ
القرار بعنايه لانه قد يؤثر عليها يقول
وزير الدفاع الالماني
تردد برلين دفع بولندا الى الاعلان عن
تشكيل تحالف يضم البلدان التي تملك دبابات
اليو بارك والمستعده لتقديمها الى كاف
منتقده المانيا على اضاعه الوقت
الى اوكرانيا وحتى لو لم نحصل على هذه
الموافقه سنستمر في تسليم دباباتنا مع
الاخرين الى اوكرانيا
التطورات تاتي في وقت تعمل فيه المانيا
على حساب كل المعادلات وعدم التورث في حرب
مباشره مع روسيا الغاضبه تقارير ذكرت
النبرلين لن ترسل دبابات الى اوكرانيا الا
اذا فعلت واشنطن الامر نفسه
بلال البوجدين العربيه
اهلا بك سيد يوري يعني فيما يخص
حزمه المساعدات الاوروبيه المنتظره بخاصه
الدبابات نتحدث والمدرعات كيف تخطط
لاستغلالها ومن الضمانات التي يمكن ان
تقدمونها كي لا يقع المحظور وتتطور الامور
الى الاسواق وهذه هي مخاوف المانيا
بالتحديد
قولي لنا ثانكيو
ان الدبابات هي لا ان اصبحت اولويه قصوى
للجيش الاوكراني لانه في هذه المرحله من
الحرب نحن بحاجه لمواصله تحرير اراضينا
بما ان النبي حاجه لمواصله عمليات الهجوم
المضاد الذي نقوم بهذه العمليات العسكريه
تحتاج
للدبابات الثقيله وقد
طالبنا بالحصول على الدبابات لفتره من
الوقت وكما شاهدنا في السابق من خلال اخرى
مثل
وكذلك مدافع
والمداف الهاوندز راينا انه بعد ما تردد
حلفاؤنا الغربيون اتخذوا القرار في نهايه
المطاف ويجب انه يقرر انه بالنسبه للمملكه
المتحده فقدت اخذت القرار
بارسال
لجذابات من طراز اثنين وسمعنا ان فرنسا
تنظر في اي ظن في تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
هناك نقاشات بهذا الشان تجري حاليا نامل
طبعا انه خلال خير في قاعده رامشتاين قبل
بدعته ايام نعمل ان تحالف
الدبابات سوف يتم شائه من اجل مساعدته
همم اختراقات كبيره حصلت اثناء
اجتماعين بمعنى ان الجنود الاوكراني سوف
يبدا تدريبهم على استخدام دبابات ونحن
نوافقون بان حلفاء الغربيين سوف يتخذون
القرار المناسب كما ان النواسقون بان
تخويف بتصعيد هي استراتيجيه خاطئه لاننا
نتعامل مع بلدها واذا راغبنا في تجنب
التصعيد هذا يعني ان اوكرا تاج الحصول على
كافه الاسلحه التي نطالب بها حتى نستطيع
هزيمه روسيا على ارضي المعركه ونستعيد
السلام سيدنا
بوكا وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه بالامس فقط
قالت ان حكومتها لن تمنع بولندا اذا حاولت
ارسال دبابات لبورد الى همم اوكرانيا
اليوم عندما وصلت الى بروكسل يبدو انها
احجمك عن اعطاء تفاصيل وكانها كما فهم
البعض تتنصل عما ورد بالامس لم تكشف اذا
كان هذا هو قرار الحكومه ام لا ما الذي
وصلكم من البولنديين المتحمسين طبعا
لارسال ليقاد ولكنه بحاجه الى اذن من
المانيا ما الذي وصلكم منهم تحديدا هل
سيرسلون هذه الدبابات قبيله المانيا ام لم
تقبل وهل تكفيكم اذا احجمت المانيا عن فعل
ذلك
اود ان اقول انه غير ملائم بالنسبه لنا
انه عقب على سياسات وقرارات داخليه
لحلفاءنا في البلدان الغربيه نحن نتفهم ان
بعض البلدان في اوروبا هي الان مستعده وقد
قال ذلك مساعد
لتزويد هذه الدبابات الى اوكرانيا بما
فيها بولندا التي عبرت على رغبتها في
تزويدي اوكرانيا
حتى وان رفضت المانيا اعطاء الاذن بذلك
وسمعنا ان من المانيا انه هناك مناقشات
ايجابيه
بشان
انه في نهايه الامر شكرا
في اوروبا وهذا
ضد كبير مقارنه بما نطالب به فنحن في
اوكرانيا همم نريد من هذه الدبابات ان
تلعب دور يغير قواعد اللعبه ونحتاج 300
دبابه وما هذا الا جزء من الدبابات
الموجوده علينا ان نتذكر ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لديها الاف من دبابات
اي برامج
فقط 300 دبابه ولكن اذا اعطت البلدان
ارقام مختلفه فنحوى سنتمكن
بجمع جيش من الدبابات من اجل القوه
الاوكراني شكرا جزيلا لك مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني من كاف تحياتنا اليك
ومن الصراع العسكري الى الصراع اخر سيظل
في صلب المعركه بين روسيا واوكرانيا حتى
لو اجل لما بعد هدوء المعارك الحديث هنا
عن حرب الاموال والذي تبدو فيه روسيا تحت
الضغط اكثر من خصمتها الاوكرانيه بالتاكيد
فمستوى صراع بين الطرفين تجاوز حدود فرض
العقوبات وتزويد كيف بالاسلحه بل امتد الى
حد التفكير في استخدام الاموال المجمده
الفكره طرحت من جديد على لسان رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي شارل الذي حث زعماء دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي على الاوروبي قدما في محادثات
بشان استخدام اصول البنك المركزي الروسي
الغايه من استخدامه هذه الاصول اعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا بعد الدمار الذي تعرضت له
من خلال الحرب المتوسطه على اراضيها
والجديد في مقترح المجلس الاوروبي استثمار
اربع هذه الاصول وليس الاصول بذاتها
الاصول الروسيه في البنوك الاوروبيه
والامريكيه ايضا هي اصول مجمده وليست
مصادره وهنا يتجلى العائق الاساسي الذي
يواجه الاتحاد الاوروبي
فالتجميد يعني ان الاصول والممتلكات تعود
الى اصحابها بمجرد رفع العقوبات من قبل
الدوله التي فرضتها في المقام الاول اما
مصادره الاصول فهي عمليه اكثر تعقيدا
وتتطلب الحصول على اذن قضائي بعد اثبات ان
هذه الاموال استخدمت في نشاط غير قانوني
ويبدو ان الاتحاد الاوروبي على درايه بهذه
الاشكاليه وهو ما يمكن تفسيره بسعيه
الاستثمار الاصول وليس الاستفاده منها
بشكل مباشر على اي حال ان الفكره ليست
بالجديده حيث طرحت من طرف اورسو لافندر
لاين رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
الممثل الاعلى للسياسه الخارجيه وهم
اللذان اكد سابقا على ضروره التفكير في
الموضوع بشكل جدي الامر كذلك في الولايات
المتحده حيث كانت وزاره العدل الامريكيه
اكدت ان واشنطن تعتزم البدء في نقل الاصول
المصادره من روسيا لصالح اوكرانيا
وفي حال تصرف في الاموال الروسيه فان ذلك
سيشكل سابقه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن
الامر ليس كذلك في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واشنطن تتحكم في اصول بمليارات
الدولار مملوكه للمصري في المركزي
الافغاني وذلك لتعويض ضحايا هجمات ال 11
من سبتمبر 2001 ولتامين مساعدات الانسانيه
للبلاد وهو المثال الذي يستند اليه
المدافعون عن الفكره داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي غير ان بعض معارضين الفكره يخشون
من ان تؤثر سلبا في السمعه الماليه
للاتحاد الاوروبي لا سيما في ما يتعلق
بالاحتياطات الاجنبيه كما ان هذه الخطوه
تتعارض مع القوانين الاوروبيه وهو ما اكده
وزير الشؤون الاقتصاديه السويسري
الاصول الروسيه المجمده الى اوكرانيا
سيكون انتهاكا للقانون هذه كانت المواقف
الاوروبيه راويه التي استعرضناها وتبدو
فيها النيه واضحه لكن من دون وجود اليه
للتنفيذ فماذا عن الموقف الروسي الموقف
فارسي طاهر لن يكون متساهلا بالتاكيد انها
سرقه بهذه الكلمات ردت موسكو على
المقترحين الامريكي والاوروبي بالاستيلاء
على الاموال الروسيه المجمده المتحدث باسم
الكربلاند مثل بسكوب اعتبر ان الاحتياطات
والاصول الروسيه في الدول الغربيه سرقت
بالفعل واضاف ان سرقه ممتلكات روسيا في
الخارج تنتهكوا جميع القوانين والاعراف
اما بنك روسيا فقد بدا اكثر واقعيه معتبرا
ان فرص دول الغربيه في اعاده الاصول
الروسيه المجمده بسبب العقوبات منخفضه
للغايه موسكو اكدت انها لن تقف مكتوفه
حياله اي اجراء يتخذه الاتحاد الاوروبي
رئيس البرلمان الروسي فيا تسلاف بولوجي
دخل على الخط محذرا الدول الغربيه من
مصادره اصول روسيا كما قال انه في حال
مصادره الاصول فان لروسيا الحق في اتخاذ
اجراءات مماثله تجاه الدول التي ستتخذ هذه
القرار هذا الاهتمام بالاصول الروسيه يعكس
قيمتها الضخمه فوفقا للارقام المعلنه من
الاتحاد الاوروبي فقد تم تجميد حوالي 300
مليار يورو من احتياطات البنك المركزي
الروسي وذلك في اطار العقوبات التي فرضتها
اوروبا على موسكو بسبب العمليه العسكريه
على اوكرانيا كما تم تجميد 19 مليار يورو
من اموال الاوليغارش الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اذا المتحدث
ضمان موافقه المستشار الالماني قبل ارسال
الدبابات لاوكرانيا يعني صلب سؤالنا قبل
قليل ليوري ساك مستشار وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني لانه تصريحات انا لينا بوك كانت
واضحه بالامس بان المانيا لن تعارض ولكن
اليوم يبدو انه لم توضح اذا كانت الحكومه
كلها موافقه على ذلك اذا كان المستشارت
موافقا على ذلك
الامريكيه فرض عقوبات جديده على ايران
الجديده
عن القمع في ايران والجهات التي تمولهم
متهمه النظام الايراني بالاعتماد على
المحاكمات السوريه والاعدامات لقمع الشعب
ب- العقوبات لم تكن امريكيه فقط وانما
اوروبيه فالاتحاد الاوروبي فرض حزمه
عقوبات رابعه على ايران استهدفت مسؤولين
كبار في قوات الامن الايرانيه والحرس
الثوريات الايرانيه على وقت الحمله
العنيفه على الاحتجاجات السلميه والافراج
عن جميع المعتقلين بشكل غير قانوني
اوروبيا ايضا اكد مسؤول السياسه الخارجي
في الاتحاد الاوروبي انه لا يمكن ادراج
الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه من دون صدور
حكم بالادانه ضده من احدى المحاكم
الاوروبيه
واحده تختصم الحرس الثوري وتنظرها المحاكم
الماليه
[موسيقى]
لكن لا يمكن ادراج الحرس الثوري الايرانيه
على قوائم الارهاب دون قرار قضائي قرار
المحكمه اولا فلا يمكن تصنيف اي شخص بسبب
كره له لذلك يجب اصدار القرار عندما تقر
دوله اوروبيه حكما رسميا بناء على اساس
قويه حينها يمكن العمل على المستوى
الاوروبي
ما ينضم الينا من بروكسل مراسل العربيه
نور الدين الفريدي اهلا بك معنا نور الدين
يعني حزمه عقوبات اوروبيه امريكيه هي
الرابعه منذ بدا العمليه العسكريه عفوا
منذ على ايران
فماذا عن التفاصيل
18 مسؤولا ايرانيا و 20 كيان من بين
المسؤولين اكثر من خمسه هم جنرالات تابعين
للحارس الثوري او منقاد الحرس الثوري في
يقودنا قوه عده يعني يعطيك امثله اكادم
احمد رئيس كربلاء في الحرس الثوري
الايراني احمد عظيمه رئيس رئيس قسم او
ثقنه او مقر النجف الاشرف في الحرس الثوري
الايراني عباس مرتدي نائب قائد الحرس
الثوري الايراني القيادات عليا في الحرس
الثوريه الايراني
الحزمه الرابعه الامر نفسه بالنسبه
للكيانات وتسعه عشر كيانا همم اغلبيه هذه
الكائنات تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني هذه
الحزمه الرابعه بمعنى الحزبات الثلاثه
السابقه في اكتوبر في نوفمبر في ديسمبر
والان في يناير ب من هناك اتجاه تصاعدي
لهاته العقوبات الاوروبيه ضد ايران وهذا
الاتجاه سيتواصل مثل ما اكد جوزيام بريل
لان ردا على قمع ايران او معان النظام
الايراني في رقم عشابي شارلي ميشيل رئيس
المجلس الاوروبي قال
ظهر اليوم ان هذه الحزمه الرابعه هي رساله
واضحه في اتجاه النظام وفي اتجاه الشعب
الايراني بنا ان الاتحاد الاوروبي لن يقف
مكتوفه الايدي طبعا هذا ليس الجانب الوحيد
في هذه العلاقه المعقده جدا الان بين
ايران والاتحاد الاوروبي لانه هناك مسائل
تتعلق بدعم روسيا دور ااران المزعزع وذوي
الحدث الثوري المخرب في اا تخريب في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط والخليج تماما
همم القضائي الواجب صدوره قبل تصنيف الحرس
الثوري الاوربيه على قائمه ارهاب ويعني
هذا الان حديث رسمي هل ما يحكى عندك بانه
هو او هي عقده حقيقيه همم او عقده يمكن
العمل عليها لحلها بسهوله ولكن همم بحاجه
الى مزيد من الوقت او انها بمجرد ذر
الرماد في العيون بمعنى انه همم ليس هناك
نيه حقيقيه بسبب عدم وجود اجماع ربما على
هذا التصنيف
طالب يحلو للاوربيين المسؤولين
والدبلوماسيين القول ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يقوم على مبادئ دوله القانون وبالتالي لا
يمكن
للاتحاد الاوروبي ان يصنف او يتهم اي كان
الحارس السوري او ايا كان من الحركات همم
في العالم دون ان تتوفر ادله همم ماديه
وانات هذه الادله ينظر فيها القضاء ويحكم
فيها القضاء سواء تعلق بالحارس الثوري او
باي تنظيم اخر في امريكا اللاتينيه او في
افريقيا او في الشرق الاوسط هذا مبدا
اساسي لماذا لان اي انسان او اي اا كيان
يحكم عليه ويعتقد له الحق في الطعني في
هذا الحكم امام محكمه العدل الاوروبيه
فردا ان المانيا ادرجت والاتحاد الاوروبي
ادراج الحرس الثوري ولكن ذهب الحرس الثوري
عن طريقه المحامين
اكد وقدم ادله تمكن تقنع المحكمه العدل
الاوروبيه بالعكس انا ذاكر المحكمه تامر
المجلسا بالغاء هذا الحكم وبسحب الحارس
الثوري من من من قائمه الارهاب حدث هذا
بالنسبه لحركات في السابق حدث هذا بالنسبه
لمجاهده خلق عندما صنفوا في مرحله ما
تنظيم الارهابيا في اوروبا وبالتالي همم
هناك خيبه سياسيه كبيره وخيبه قانونيه
للمجلس اذا ما همم شككت المحكمه في صدقيته
قررته ولكن هذه القاعديه قاعده اساسيه
تتعلق همم بالموضوع همم موضوع القوائم ده
كله هناك يبدو ربما نوع من
التضارب بينما
فهيمه الاسبوع الماضي وقيل الاسبوع الماضي
وما قيل وما تمكنا من نقله دعنا نقول بدء
من يوم الجمعه حتى الساعه
بيعوا رجاله هناك
كبار المسؤولين وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
هنا رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل
فوندالين تحدثت عن دعمها ادراج الحرس
الثوري الايرانيه في قائمه الارهاب ولكن
الحقيقه ان السيده فوندر لين عندما تحدثت
هذا الكلام في منتدى دافوس لم تستجر رجال
القانون في في ديوانه وبالتالي
وكالات الانباء نقلت هذا الكلام تعاملت
معه وسائل الاعلام كانه على اساس انه خبر
رئيسي ولكن هذا الخبر كان منقوص او كان
كان التعامل معه من دون النظر الى الجوانب
القانونيه
سياسيه لم يلبي او لم يراعي كل همم يعني
الاجراءات القانونيه الواجب اتباعها قبل
صدور مثل هكذا قرار واضح جدا شكرا جزيلا
على الكره هذه الشروحات والمعلومات مراسل
العربيه من بروكسل نور الدين شكرا
لنترك الملف ملف تصنيف الحرس الثوري
ونتحول الى الجديد في انشطه هذه
الميليشيات الاساسيه بالنسبه لسياسه ايران
الخارجيه فملف المشروع الايراني للدفاع
الجوي في سوريا لم يبح بعد بكل اسراره
فبعد الكشف عن افشال المشروع من طرف
اسرائيل بدات تتسرب معلومات اكثر حول
خبايا هذا المشروعه صحيفه ايران
انترناشونال لبست اكثر في خفايا هذا الملف
لتكشف النقاب عن المزيد من التفاصيل
البدايه بالعقل المدبر للمشروع الايراني
حيث قالت الصحيفه ان داوود جعفري احد قاده
القوات الجويه للحارس الثوري الايراني هو
الذي انشا هذه الشبكه
قبل ان يقتل في ظروف غامضه في سوريا شهر
نوفمبر الماضي في عمليه اتهمت الطهران
اسرائيل بالقيام بها
ذراع الايمن لجعفري لم يكن سوا فريدون
محمود سقي وهو قائد فرقه خاصه في الحرس
الثوري تم تكليفه باداره جزء من المشروع
فان المهمه اسندت لاحد كبار المسؤولين في
الحرس الثوري الايراني ويتعلق الامر بجواد
غافري الذي طرد من سوريا في الخليفه
الماضي
قبل ان يتم تعويضه بمحمد رضا زاهدي احد
قادت الفيلق القدس تابعه للحرس الثوري
الايراني
وهو ما تطرقت اليه ايران انترناشونال التي
قالت ان الناشطين لبنانيين من حزب الله
كان مقربين من جعفري عاملاه في هذا
المشروع
الدفاع الايرانيه كانت تتلقى المساعده من
عملاء السريين على درايه باستخدام معدات
حساسه للغايه في مجال الدفاع الجوي دون ان
ننسى ان هذا المشروع تم بشكل مشترك مع قوه
النظام السوري بهدف تمكينه زرع نظام
ايرانيه استقلنا للدفاع الجوي من داخل
سوريا
[موسيقى]
ماذا وظفت ايران تحديدا في هذا المشروع
الذي صرفت من اجله عشرات الملايين
منصل الدفاع الجوي قامت ايضا بمساعده
النظام السوري على تحديث مجموعه من
الرادارات الخاصه به بغرض الكشف عن
الهجمات الاسرائيليه ومنعها بشكل اساسي ضد
المؤسسات الايرانيه في سوريا
صاروخ صياد الذي يعمل بالوقود الصلب والذي
تم الكشف عنه في نوفمبر الماضي وتم دمج
القذيفه بمنظومه الدفاع الجوي بافار ثلاثه
سبعه ثلاثه والقادره على كشف اهداف تبعد ب
320 كيلومترا
[موسيقى]
طيب هناك تصحيح من رويترز للخبر الذي
اوردناه قبل قليل ليس لخبرينا نحن لخبرهم
هم يصححون لانفسهم يقولون لانه موضوع
بولندا دوده الرئيس البولندي هو الذي قال
ذلك الكلام وليس المتحدث باسم بوتين لجهه
ضروره ان يدعم المستشار الالماني وزيره
خارجيه في موضوع تسليم دبابات ليطارد الى
اوكرانيا الموافقه على تسليم بولندا
دبابات الى اوكرا
الى بريطانيا يا طاهر حيث اختفى العشرات
من الاطفال الاطفال طالبين اللجوء غير
المصحوبين بذويهم في بريطانيا في ظروف
غامضه
عصابات اجرام
الاطفال من طالب اللجوء كانوا يقيمون في
هذا الفندق الذي تديره وزاره الداخليه
يثير صدمه كبيره في الاوساط السياسيه
والحقوقيه في بريطانيا مع كشف تحقيق انما
يقارب من 80 طفلا لا يزالون في عداد
المفقودين
واقعه تقشعر لها الابدان بالرمي من
التحذيرات المتكرره لوزاره الداخليه بان
الاطفال اللاجئين غير مسحوبين بدويهم
مستهدفون من قبل الشبكات الاجراميه وربما
يتم الاتجار ببعضهم بعيدا عن الفندق الذي
ياويهم
وكانه لا تتوقع ان يحدث في اي مكان نهيك
في مكان معين هنا في المملكه المتحده
وتحديد مكانهم ومعرفه سبب اختفائهم
حالات اختفاء اطفال اللاجئين التي وصفها
احد الموظفين مع شركه لحمايه الاطفال
متعاقده مع وزاره الداخليه سجلت ايضا في
فنادق اخرى ما دفع القياده العماليه في
مجلس برايتون الى المطالبه باجراء تحقيق
عاجل في الاطفال المفقودين
الاطفال في امان وحصلنا على ضمانات بان كل
شيء على ما يرام ومن ثم بدانا نسمع
باشاعات ان الامور ليست كذلك
وكشفت بيانات رسميه قبل اربعه اشهر انما
222 من طالب اللجوء فقدوا من فنادقات تشرف
عليها وزاره الداخليه وحينها يعترف
الوزراء بانه ليست لديهم فكره عن مكان
وجودهم
المعارضه انتقدت وزاره الداخليه لاخفاقها
في حمايه سلامه الاطفال او قمع العصابات
الاجراميه التي تعرضهم للخطر وطلبت بوضعه
ترتيبات جديده لحمايتهم على وجه السرعه
والكشف عن عدد المفقودين والاجراءات التي
تم اتخاذها للعثور عليهم من مدينه
بريطانيا العربيه
والخارجيه الامريكيه تقول لاننا فنلندا
والسويد جاهزتان للدخول في حلف النيتول
مقوله معكم لمتابعه ايضا في العربيه 360
شوارع الصين التي كان بعضها يخلو من
الماره عادت كما كانت لا مكان فيها حتى
للمره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تسريحات الموظفين في
قطاع التكنولوجيا بالجمله مستمره فما الذي
حل بالقطاع حتى وصل الى هذا الحد ومعلقه
كورونا متابعه
حمولته الزائده ربما يلخص هذا المفهوم ما
قامت به شركات التكنولوجيا العملاقه خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره من موجات تشريح بالالاف
طالت موظفين وحتى المتعاقدين لكن لا يمكن
فهمه هذا الفعل دون دراسه ما حدث في عامين
غلب عليهما كورونا وتاثيره على سلوك الناس
والشركات فجاه وجد قطاع التكنولوجيا نفسه
في بؤره الاهتمام والتركيز مع الاغلاقات
التي عمت العالم وارقت الموظفين والطلاب
في منازلهم
حينها تضاعف الطلب على اجهزه الكمبيوتر
المحمول لتلبيه معايير العمل عن بعد تضاعف
معه حجم التسوق عبر الانترنت مع توقف في
اغلب المحل عن استقبال الزبائن حتى
التسليه اغلقت الملاعب والحدائق ليصبح
الميدان الوحيد المتاح العاب الفيديو
والافلام لذا حين تضاعف كل هذا كان لابد
لعدد العاملين في هذه الشركات
ايواكب الزياده لكن الان انتهت الاغلاقات
وعدت الامور الى طبيعتها لتفكر الشركات في
التاقلمي مع وضعها الجديد فما عوده الحياه
الى طبيعتها وتراجع الارادات كان لابد من
التخلص من الحمل الزائد لكن ازمتين اخرين
ظهرت في الصوره
الاولى هي التضخم واتجاه اغلب الدول لرفع
اسعار الفائده
والثانيه والتي تعد نتيجه للاولى وهي
الركود التي بدات مؤشراته في الظهور
بمختلف الاسواق
50 الف موظفين دفعوا ثمن ما حدث خاصه في
شركات عمالقه التكنولوجيا امازون وجوجل
ومايكروسوفت وميتا لكن اخطر ان هذه
الارقام حدثت بينما لم يدخل الاقتصاد
العالمي مرحله الركود فقط ترك الباب جاسم
محسن العربيه
مع تركيا
الفرات يفيض نهر المشكلات في العام الماضي
فقط راويه شهدت ربع الاسر العراقيه تراجعا
كبيرا في محصلها الزراعيه والعام الحالي
قد يشهد المزيد
الى صوره اليوم الان في نهار يوم جديد في
سوق كراتشي في البارد يكفيهم حطب او ما
تبقى منه لاشعال نار صغيره تبث باجسادهم
المنهكه بعضا من الدفع
جوالات تحتاج الى من يحملها والشاحنات في
انتظار من يشعل محركاتها يعلمون انهم
سينسون البرد حين تسخن عضلاتهم من الجهد
حين يتذكرون
الافواه المفتوحه
فيديو اليوم من الصين من الصين المغلقه
قبل اسابيع
والكل سيذهل اليوم مما يراح بالامس فقط
سجل نظام النقل العام اكثر من 17 مليون
رحله ركاب في اول ايام العام الجديد
عن ان الصين قررت في عامها الجديد ان
تهرول وراء العالم وان تهجر خوفها من
كورونا هي الصدفه اذا في العمل
هو عام الارنب
لازم الركض يعني
صهيب مساء الخير مساء الخير انا بالفعل
اضحك من قصه العام الارنب والركب يعني انه
هناك ازدحام وركض سريع
مساء الخير عليكم
كيف الحال
اهلا وسهلا اهلا وسهلا
[موسيقى]